i want to pull up this story real quick
because you guys had mentioned this
before the show and it's an interesting
story axios is reporting biden officials
fear mass migration event if coveted
policies end axios reports u.s
intelligence officials are privately
bracing for a massive influx of more
than 170 000 migrants the mexico border
if covet era policies that allow instant
expulsions during the public health
emergency are ended sources with direct
knowledge of the discussions tell axios
the response underway includes a newly
created and previously unreported
southwest border coordination center
essentially a war room to coordinate an
intra-agent interagency response
so they're basically saying the title 42
has been used more than one million
times to rapidly expel migrants at the
southern border without hearing asylum
claims but the trump era order wasn't
set up to be permanent and senior biden
officials are preparing for its end as
the virus is brought under control
this means that when title 42 ends
all of a sudden 170 000 migrates are
going to rush the border
because they can't be instantly expelled
and that means our immigration system
won't be able to handle a massive influx
of that an influx of that magnitude
they're already not able to handle it
we've had for the last every month since
biden has been elected
has the people crossing the border has
increased in january from from january
to february it just went up another
seven percent but our media has totally
forgotten about the border crisis in
general they don't talk about it anymore
our cbp is already overrun so they're
they're saying they're going to they
they need to uh beef it up they're
already under prepared what should we do
well just remember my school example 170
000 people if one-third if it's mom and
dad and one child
what's the third of 170 is that like 55
60 not quite sixty thousand that's right
so it's not six more school districts in
one event
and when you talk about asylum people
have to remember that when you when you
request asylum asylum from what
religious persecution
fear of your government there's actually
categories for it it can't just be my
neighborhood's bad there's no money and
all that kind of stuff and the drug
cartels are bad i mean i get that they
live in bad neighborhoods and your heart
goes out to them i get that
but they come here uneducated and they
come here to take jobs right that
americans from americans and in many
instances and so they have to ought to
go to the united states embassy whether
it's bolivia whether it's argentina
whether it's mexico guatemala and apply
for asylum there
and the best thing biden could have done
was to let trump's policies stay into
effect on energy
on
on immigration and a whole lot of things
that baidu has just done nothing from
first day but he starts reversing them
all and we're seeing the effect of it
you see there's there was a video
one of the migrant caravans several
years ago they were coming from i think
honduras they're in they're in mexico at
the southern uh they're in southern
mexico
and they get the announcement that
mexico will offer them all asylum and
refugee status in mexico and someone in
the caravan yells how many of you
want to stay in mexico and then he says
how many of you want to go to america
and they're like yeah
so they were they were given asylum i i
it's crazy to me because i think the
issue is
for uh people on the left i gotta tell
you man they think mexico is a desert
they think mexico is all sepia toned
they watched movies and it's just like
it's on narcos they're like this is the
entire pokemon like every every movie
about mexico they just set your tone and
then i'm like have you ever been to
mexico city it is a city it is a big
city they have buffalo wild wings it's
awesome
vox had ran a quote from one of the
migrants in the caravan several years
ago and they somewhat a journalist from
a french journalist asked this migrant
why do you want to go to america and he
said i miss buffalo wild wings and i'm
like well hold on there a minute i
absolutely relate to that b-dubs is
awesome but they have b-dubs in mexico
yeah i went to mexico city and
specifically sought out of buffalo wild
wings and i got me some honey barbecue
wings with ranch dressing and it was
great it's funny you say that about
mexico because everybody thinks texans
ride horses every day
which the greenies would probably be
okay with if we rode over here on horses
but i keep reminding them that horses
have
emissions that's the truth yeah big
stinky ones yeah well tim you made a
point earlier about believing that
basically everyone should have the
opportunity to enter this country and
part of what's sad about the current
development
what's that yeah no exactly exactly
and part of the issue is there is a lot
of opportunity for people to or there
would be more opportunity for people to
be able to enter through the legal
channels if our system was not clogged
up with people who are jumping in line
to try to enter the country and i cannot
think of anything more suicidally stupid
for a nation to do maybe a few things
but not many things more suicidally
stupid for a nation to do than say
instead of taking the people who want to
follow our laws and respect our culture
let's just bring in everybody who's
willing to violate our norms and break
our laws and not respect our nation and
tell the people who want to respect it
that they can't come because we brought
in too many of the people in the former
category or they have to be and they are
already way down in the line it takes
years and years and so now you've got an
immigration system that as i pointed out
early judges and courts and clerks and
all those kinds of things now that
people are trying to do it legally are
pushed way back because of those jumping
ahead our
asylum court so once they come here they
get released and they're supposed to go
to asylum courts they're backed up for
about four years so they get let into
the country and then for four years
they're allowed to do whatever they want
work wherever they want
do whatever they need to do before they
even get a hearing to see if they should
be deported or not you look at some of
the news reports have been coming out
for the past year so it's much much
worse than that we're hearing uh there
was the video footage released from uh i
think it was westchester new york where
the bind administration has been
smuggling undocumented children illegal
immigrant kids into various states and
you actually had a federal contractor
tell a local cop if the american people
knew what we were doing and he says what
do you mean the government has betrayed
them wow these are these are we had
tennessee
found out because of secret video that
these these uh illegal immigrant kids
were being flown in the middle of the
night into these other states and then
just released
it is it is not just that our courts are
backed up it's that
i view this as the biden administration
is desperately trying to sweep under the
rug what's happening you had those
videos coming out from accountant texas
of the kids under the under the highway
remember that absolutely about 15 000
but it was the biggest biden group that
he ever assembled
you know oh yeah the largest crowd
no you're not wrong they did have five
shirts on too yeah well so i think what
they're doing is we don't want the media
to see this so just take the kids in the
middle of the night and fly him to a
random location you know tim what you're
describing almost sounds like a swamp
oh yeah
amazing that there's bureaucrats in
there that they want to do it their way
and there's so much corrupt and so much
stuff as you point as that guy pointed
out once you just
related their government our government
has betrayed us
in a lot of ways i i think
it's sad to say maybe it's not so much
that our government has but that our
government has been
for the law for a very long time there
are people in our government who don't
care about us don't care about the
country and i think it's apparent when
you see what's happening with schools
how they're teaching that america is bad
or evil they really just don't like this
place
and there's that joke about man all of
those freedom-loving cubans who want to
escape and make it or venezuelans we'd
love for them to come cherishing the
ideas of freedom and liberty and those
who want socialism and communism and
hate america can go to the countries
that also hate america it's like you
know we've got a disproportionate uh we
gotta
have like a prisoner swap or a
population swap right that's the joke
yeah i mean one can only dream though
it's not a joke
you know here's here's what i'll say
i've said it before i have infinitely
more respect
for the honduran who says i'm going to
travel you know thousands of miles
through desert risking my life because
america is awesome as opposed to these
leftists in the united states who are
like america is evil and wrong and
colonial that being said
jumping the line over someone who has
the same belief and says america is
awesome i'm going to do it right
i would prefer the people waiting in
line believing in america absolutely the
ones allowed in well you know that they
believe in the rule of law they're going
to come they're going to do their dead
best to be a a
good citizen it's just that simple yeah
just that simple yeah and for the most
part this isn't the case 100 of the time
and i'm speaking anecdotally but when i
meet legal immigrants they tend to be
very patriotic people who lean
conservative and they really do not like
illegal immigration they don't and
sheamus i speak a lot of people don't
know this but i speak i mean i speak
spanish so when i'm down on the border
we talk about a
request for asylum you know when you
talk to those families down there many
of them through tears especially the
ladies it breaks your heart the mama's
got a little baby or maybe a
three-year-old five-year-old someone had
three kids with them when you speak to
them you say you know why are you here
what are you doing blah blah they're not
talking about asylum i'm afraid for you
don't think of me i don't i have fear
they're saying
i need a job yeah and that's their claim
and so you see that every single day on
the border you know it's really crazy to
me is that
several hundred years ago
people from uh all over the world mostly
europeans you know they decided to get
on boats because they needed jobs and
they risked their lives on you know
sailing for three months i think like
what 20 percent of people on these ships
from europe to north america would die
of dysentery yeah like that scurvy or
whatever gross thing and uh
what happened when they made it here
there was nothing
you they made their jobs absolutely so
they would just they you know don't get
me wrong a lot of the early settlers
nearly died and that's why we have
thanksgiving cold winters cold winter is
bad man when uh when game of thrones
says winter is coming people people in
the united states don't really
understand what that means anymore
because we have strawberries in the
winter due to technology yeah but it you
know when we're talking about you know
we've got chickens we had a garden for a
while and we're thinking about how much
food are we producing for ourselves
more as a hobby how many eggs how many
berries how many tomatoes and then fall
hits and we're like zero nothing the
berries are no longer being produced the
gardens are all just basically done and
dead the chicken production drops
dramatically we have some chickens that
lay throughout and i thought to myself
like man if we did not have supermarkets
with imported avocados from mexico and
we were reliant on ourselves for food
what would we do well you could have low
wild wings yeah
absolutely yeah you drive through you
you climb mountains and you may get
there you probably hunt you know you
hunt and prepare but most importantly
you'd store up food throughout the
summer to prepare for the winter you
know that's a great point i i want our
kids to be learning this stuff they're
not getting it in school and virginia
woke up didn't they kicked out a bunch
of state legislators because of the way
they treated school parents and you all
saw by the way parenthetically in new
jersey uh back in this last november
they we unelected the top democrat in
new jersey uh in the senate uh truck
driver beat him spent less than what was
it i don't know hundred dollars or less
than a thousand i don't know six or
eight hundred dollars i don't know if
y'all saw that story a trucker beat him
and that was kind of good news and bad
news the good news is yes we knocked out
the top democrat in new jersey the bad
news is darn we lost another trucker
we got we got a trucker but back to the
kids
they're not learning this stuff and i
went in to get my oil changed here a
while back and i talked this kid was was
very you know impersonable that kind of
stuff personable and so i said it was
thanksgiving i said what's thanksgiving
bob he said well it's thanksgiving
he's about 21 or 2 years old he goes
thanksgiving you know that's when we
give thanks i said well sure i get that
right that's i got that but do you know
where the holiday word came from
um i said who are we giving thanks to
for example if we're given things who
are giving thanks to he said
um
was is it the indians
and i said oh my gosh bob let me sit
down let me talk to you for just a
minute and then i relate to him the
story of people coming over here and the
fact that the indians did help you know
help them learn how to farm and raise
stuff like like we know but our kids are
not being taught the history of our kind
of our country
and so so it's fascinating you know my
point was so many people say i need work
yeah and i wonder
you know what can you do to just go and
try and survive
i guess the reality is
you know we we were talking about this
in the members
segment the other day and it was you
know i think it was fairly brutal and
probably offensive to a lot of people
we talk about what schools are doing to
people's children in terms of
indoctrination
and i would often say to parents and to
people you need to stand up for what you
believe in if you're at a company and
they're saying these things and people
would always say like oh i can't risk
losing my job because you know i have
kids and i thought to myself
would how much you know how much would
you be willing to sacrifice your kid to
this indoctrination this dogma for the
sake of comfort
so when you see people come to you at
the border and say i need i need a job.
it's because a job in america means air
conditioning it means a refrigerator it
means a it's clean running water
and the reality of the world is that
you would be digging a hole and making a
fire and hunting a deer and having to
find ways to survive from the ground up
but because the united states is wealthy
people are coming here and what they're
saying is please let me share in your
wealth i totally get it this country is
awesome but there's a finite amount of
wealth we don't have infinite resources
so i wonder if what we really need to
start doing for ourselves and for
everybody is
help teach people how to farm how to
develop how to how to you know
farming i think is one of the most
important things if people are having
issues can we help them be
self-sufficient through education
instead of just saying come here and
bask in the wealth are you talking about
giving money to other nations to teach
them how to be self-sufficient teach
them how to farmer do you want them to
learn it and do it here
well
that's tough i would probably say
setting up programs with our oversight
in their countries to set up farming
programs and not have people come here
well we have a lot of ngos and
for sure that do that right and they
teach them how to you know have a clean
water and electricity
oh yeah i have friends who did stuff
like that with africa yeah and it's you
know giving them uh information on
farming practices and crop rotation
how to set up wells and everything does
infinitely more
you give a man a fish you feed him for a
day you teach a man a fish to feed him
for the rest of his life when you talk
about we don't have infinite resources
and you're exactly right i remember and
this is what the left is doing they just
want more and more people bigger
government met the government depending
on them and keep voting them in office
there was a scottish professor i think
the university of edinburgh in 17
something who literally his name was
alexander teitler who literally said
back then that democracy can only exist
until the rank and file people discover
they can vote themselves funds from the
general treasury that's right and when
they do
it's over and we're getting dangerously
close that's right thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there